handelt es sich bei den jüngsten
ufo-sichtungen um alien raumschiff genau
das ist laut nasa chef bill nelson
durchaus denkbar für zahlreiche ufo
sichtungen in der vergangenheit gibt es
laut nasa jedenfalls immer noch
keinerlei erklärungen jetzt zurück der
nasa administrator unerwartet offen
seine meinung raus und die ist nicht
ohne warum er das tut dafür gibt es gute
gründe klicks umsatz im future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannendes heinz theus
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
herzlich willkommen okay das ist jetzt
starker tobak von anfang an irgendwo da
draußen muss es sich verbergen
außerirdisches leben davon sind
mittlerweile die meisten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit überzeugt fest steht das
universum ist so gigantisch groß und
somit auch die wahrscheinlichkeit riesig
dass es außerirdisches leben gibt
möglicherweise handelt es sich sogar um
intelligente wesen hoch entwickelte
zivilisation zudem sollten wir
mittlerweile eine reale chance haben
diesen näher zu kommen leistungsfähige
teleskope
forschungssatelliten und aufwendige
weltraummissionen sollten zumindest
theoretisch in der lage sein endlich
auch beweisen für außerirdisches leben
aufzuspüren denn viele fragen sind immer
noch offen wo genau hält es sich
versteckt über welche technologien
verfügen diese potenziellen aliens und
sind sie möglicherweise sogar in der
lage zu uns auf die erde zu reisen die
chefs der nasa haben sich zu diesen
fragen in der vergangenheit eher bedeckt
gehalten anders aber nasa chef bill
nelson der im märz diesen jahres vom us
präsident joe biden als künftiger nasa
administrator nominiert worden war im
mai trat clarence william bill nelson
junior das amt an jetzt hat er sich zu
den ufo sichtungen der vergangenheit
geäußert und das auf spektakuläre art
und weise erhält es tatsächlich für
vorstellbar dass es sich bei den
jüngsten ufo sichtung um raumschiff von
außerirdischen
handeln könnte eine premiere denn in
solch einer deutlichkeit hat noch keiner
seiner vorgänger im diese möglichkeit
aufgezeigt wovon genau geht der nasa
chef aus und was bedeutet das für unsere
suche nach außerirdischem leben die
antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen gibt es jetzt hier bei pixum
science in future fest steht die ganze
welt ist im ufo fieber oder besser
gesagt es geht ja um sogenannte hubs das
steht für an
identifizieren phänomen auf deutsch
nicht identifizierte luft phänomene so
die neuere und laut fachleuten exaktere
bezeichnung denn ob es tatsächlich
objekte sind das ist nämlich wer weiß
also schon seit jahrzehnten beschäftigt
sich die ganze welt damit doch in den
vergangenen monaten hat dieses thema
noch einmal an brisanz gewonnen im
sommer diesen jahres juni 2021 hatten
die usa ja die bombe platzen lassen das
us verteidigungsministerium und die us
geheimdienste hatten den lang ersehnten
bericht zum thema veröffentlicht wir
hatten hier weil ich so science and
future ausführlich darüber berichten
demnach ist es denkbar dass es sich bei
143 sichtungen von unbekannten
flugobjekten kurzum flugobjekte einer
außerirdischen zivilisation handelt oder
ob es also um das noch mal zu erwähnen
zumindest kann dieses trotz einer
intensiven untersuchung nicht
ausgeschlossen werden 18 dieser
beobachtung sind demnach sogar komplett
unerklärlich gerätselt wird vor allem
über verschiedene videos aus den
vergangenen jahren auf vielen von ihnen
sind flugobjekte zu sehen die sich
absolut seltsam verhalten so wie wir es
auf der erde sonst nicht kennen und es
auch eigentlich nicht erklärbar selbst
renommierte fachleute schließen
mittlerweile nicht mehr aus dass diese
mysteriöse flugobjekte von
außerirdischen spezies stammen könnten
zeigen sie sich also nun langsam oder
können sie sich nicht mehr vor uns
verbergen und auch der nasa
administrator bill nelson hat sich jetzt
auf spektakuläre art und weise zu diesem
thema geäußert er ist ehemaliger
astronaut und politiker der
demokratischen partei im wikipedia
artikel zu seiner person wird er
folgendermaßen charakterisiert er tritt
zurückhaltend und bescheiden auf und ist
auch wegen seiner spärlichen präsenz im
fernsehen nicht weiterhin bekannt das
macht seine aussagen die er jetzt in
einem team der university virginia
getroffen hat umso spektakulärer den
zweifelsohne ist es das erste mal dass
ich an nasa-chef so konkret zum thema
äußert demnach was man bis heute einfach
nicht was bei vielen ufo sichtung
wirklich dahinter steckt es gebe
schlichtweg keine erklärung dazu nutzen
wer bin ich denn behaupten zu können
dass die erde der einzige ort ist an dem
eine lebensform lebt die so zivilisiert
und organisiert ist wie die unsere er
macht deutlich dass es nicht
auszuschließen ist dass es einen
zusammenhang zwischen militärischen
sichtungen von unidentifizierten
flugobjekten ufos und der suche nach
außerirdischem leben geben könnte
insgesamt ist von 300 solcher sichtungen
da sogar die rede die es in den
vergangenen 17 jahren gegeben hat und
deren hintergründe bis heute vollkommen
unklar seien dazu bill nelson ich habe
mit den piloten gesprochen sie wissen
dass sie etwas gesehen haben und ihre
radar haben auch etwas erfasst doch was
genau die piloten gesehen haben dass es
weiter unklar wenn man also davon
ausgeht dass es außerirdisches leben
gibt stellt sich weitere fragen wie
sieht dieses aus ist es uns gut gesonnen
oder hat es uns menschen möglicherweise
als feinde oder konkurrenten auserkoren
falls sie sich um hoch entwickelte
zivilisationen handelt sind diese um zu
überlegen und über welche technologien
verfügen sie sind sie in der lage zu zu
reisen wenn ja haben sie es ihm bereits
getan oder haben sie es vor eine
berechtigte frage vor allem eben mit dem
hintergrund dass das universum ebenso
gigantisch groß ist demnach müssten die
distanzen die mögliche kosmische
zivilisation überwinden müssen um zur
erde so lange schon wirklich riesig sein
fraglich ist also ob das selbst mit
einer sehr fortschrittlichen auf technik
ausgestattet möglich wäre ist es also
realistisch dass raumschiffe die von
intelligenten außerirdischen oder
intelligenten roboter konstruiert wurden
millionen jahre zu erde reisen und wenn
ja warum sollten diese sich dann vor
allem über dem westen der usa bei ihren
riskanten und erstaunlichem flugmanövern
fotografieren und filmen lassen diese
überlegungen lassen einen schnell seinem
anderen gedanken bereits im vergangenen
jahr hatte das pentagon drei videos mit
als nicht identifizieren eingestuften
flugobjekten veröffentlicht in diesem
zusammenhang sagt der ehemalige
stellvertretende verteidigungsminister
für geheimdienste christopher nennen die
anderen aufnahmen zeigen langsamere
flugobjekte in niedriger höhe diese
könnten einen staatlichen akteur wie
china oder russland zugeschrieben werden
nicht ganz auszuschließen dass mächte
wie china oder russland dahinter stecken
und somit fortschrittliche technologien
testen wollen möglicherweise hyperschall
flugkörper die besonders wendig sind
eine entscheidende frage also für die
usa handelt es sich möglicherweise um
neue rüstungstechnik ihn von anderen
staaten diese frage ist für die
weltmacht usa sogar durchaus
entscheidender als die frage nach der
existenz von außerirdischen leben das us
militär will natürlich nicht offen legen
wieder der genauer kenntnisstand ist
denn dann hätten andere länder ja die
möglichkeit rückschlüsse darauf zu
ziehen inwieweit die usa solche objekte
orten und zuordnen können offiziell
können die vereinigten staaten ist aber
immer noch nicht benennen was sich da
offenbar wiederholt in ihrem luftraum ab
spielt dazu christoph am allen der
ehemalige stellvertretende
verteidigungsminister für geheimdienste
wir glauben unser luftraum sei sicher
tatsächlich haben fluggeräte straffrei
militärische sperrzone überflogen und
das regelmäßig über mehrere jahre auf
der anderen seite fragt man sich dann
aber auch warum mächte wie china oder
russland diese ausgerechnet über
kalifornien testen sollten dazu nasa
administrator bill nelson in seinem
aktuellen vortrag wir hoffen dass es
sich nicht um einen gegner hier auf der
erde handelt er über diese art von
technologie verfügt weitaus
zurückhaltender in dieser sache war sein
vorgänger steve wood schickt auch er
wurde natürlich mal zu seiner meinung
zum thema außerirdisches leben gefahren
lachend hatte er darauf geantwortet dass
es sich bei dieser frage um eine frage
handele die sehr schwer zu beantworten
sei jede weltraummissionen aber sei
darauf ausgelegt nach spuren von leben
zu suchen wir bringen also unser wissen
in diesem bereich voran aber bis jetzt
haben wir keine außerirdischen gefunden
warum also gibt sicht der nasa chef will
nelson derzeit zu offen was sie bisher
ungelösten fragen zur außerirdischen
leben angeht möglicherweise verfolgt er
damit das ziel das interesse der
menschen an diesem thema weiterhin
hochzuhalten denn die geplanten mars
missionen der nasa die sind teuer und
rückenwind von gesellschaft und politik
schadet einen solchen mammut projekt
natürlich nicht ganz im gegenteil klar
geht es bei der geplanten mars mission
nicht nur um die suche nach
außerirdischem leben doch ohne frage
würde der kleinste nachweis einer
fossilen maß mikrobe unser komplettes
weltbild revolutionieren denn dann
können wir davon ausgehen dass auf dem
frühen mars leben entstanden ist sowie
auf der erde eben auch aber gänzlich
unabhängig davon und der schluss daraus
wäre spektakulär denn dann könnte es
sicher noch viel mehr planeten oder
monde im universum geben die bewohnt
sind wow haben außerirdische uns bereits
entdeckt ein forschungsteam hat diese
frage genauer untersucht und kommt zu
sehr spannenden ergebnissen also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren also
unbedingt den abo button mit dem
mauszeiger oder dem finger mal anklicken
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran